I didn't tell you guys my what the name
of this kid is that's taking to my knees
typical huh
okay I'm gonna have you guess drywall
it's the name of the name of a band
creed Koopa stank some 41
okay one of their album okay one of
their albums is the name of the place
we're going to tomorrow you to baby's
name is you to know the prom guy my
niece's name is Yuto how do you spell
that you know what's worse than that you
be forty forty love even [ __ ] scarier
yeah but you two could still be can it
could still be like the way if you say
it not like you to the pool yeah that's
how you say it actually say you thought
yeah so that's his name you do not you
two nothing what are you yeah how do you
spell it is it you - I honestly I think
it's you - what if I had a friend
growing up his name was f3 well God let
the other three like the keyboard they
like I need to like stop my computer
restarted after yeah yeah was the baby
conceived like near a computer and the
dad sitting there and they go what do we
name it he's Francisco 2/3 Wow
that's [ __ ] amazing yeah and then I
had brothers who I used to swim with one
was seven and the the younger one was
eight that's their name see that's why
do you know what you're right we should
become more creative we should be yeah
yeah you know I mean I think f3 is a
little too far that's that's too much
yeah that's too future let's try to look
on the room now yeah yeah but I think
that we will fit you know what we'll
have a contest on the podcast if we have
a baby yeah we'll go we'll do name
contest I am NOT gonna leave it up to
this level
no I'm what I'm saying no I'm saying
that will you use it as an option called
nosotros behind
name just a middle name both sides were
yeah yeah that's not you guys yeah let's
not be faulted we love you guys just you
know no they get the middle name come on
it's a by pure oh if I really Shelly
papaya it's edible by a single what is
your shangri-la shangri-la I can't hide
it what's your middle name
legal now the I co Li sure that's your
mom's maiden name so I don't have
Shangri is my real middle name because
my mom that's a good one that's a pretty
good one and Steve is my mom's maiden
George Thomas Thomas that's a great name
Shelby George Thomas Wow very very
traditional
I like Thomas better than I like George